Hello everybody.
Hi, hi.
Howdy duty.
Welcome in.
Hi.
I'm so sleepy.
I'm so tired.
My nose is a little stuff today too.
Oh gosh.
And these birds, they need to shut up.
Sorry, I have less, they keep coming out and I keep hearing
it over and over again.
That, that part right there.
Hi, so tired.
Hi, how bad is my jet lag?
It's so annoying because, like, the first day always, I'm
like, I'm so good.
I'm awake the whole day I got this I have no jet lag And
then the second day The second night I can't sleep And then
If I do sleep I wake up really early Nice hat Thank you I
thought that maybe This would be appropriate for The beasts
In the forest And
Uh, being...
What are we- what's our job?
Um, what did I get hired to do again?
What's the fire- not a fire watch.
A ranger.
A home home on the range.
Hello, me too, and viewers like you, my advice for the day
do not get addicted to nasal spray.
Yeah, that's actually a thing people get addicted to is the
nasal sprays.
apparently the where the beast there's like there's some
things in this what look here oh what is that what could
that be what could that be wait really yeah yeah people get
addicted to like nasal sprays because what's the word
there's a specific ingredient.
It starts with an A, I think.
Raw dog in the time zones is never fine.
Hang in there.
Mean to attack you!
Amphetamine, no.
Apples, no.
Acid, no.
Afrin!
Afrin is the ingredient.
Because it like makes your note, if you have a stuffy note,
it makes your nose so clear that people like will constantly
use it and sometimes people get addicted what is your go-to
American meal after an overseas trip I'm eating Culver's
right now mine is Alfred is the name of a brand oh I didn't
know well that's how little I know about it because I don't
use it um I might go to is Taco Bell.
Whenever I come back from a trip, I'm crazy.
I'm crazing?
I'm crazing.
I'm craving Taco Bell.
Don't get addicted to nasal sprays.
Just do ibuprofen.
Let's do ibuprofen together.
Did you try the Baja Blast Pie?
Wasn't it like a liver?
Wait, what's a limited time thing?
I heard like also places were selling out.
I'm crazing it.
I'm crazing the food.
It's making me crazy.
I'm craving it so much.
I'm crazing.
She's grazing.
That's my goat.
Can mint be the new Taco Bell mascot?
I think I like Taco Bell too much.
I think it's like my truest guilty pleasure.
fast food that I like Taco Bell too much maybe but my go-to
is either five layer burrito or the crunch wrap supreme
yeah yeah Taco Bell at midnight kind of goes hard yeah yeah
mmm five layers so good I know I know, wait, do they still
have the seven layer?
I remember getting that in the past, too.
Baja Minto.
Yeah, look at my hair.
Look at me.
I'm the Baja Blash.
You just blend me up and serve me in a pie.
Happy Thanksgiving.
Seven layers in this economy.
They brought back the seven layer town.
temporarily.
Ah, I see.
I see.
Sponsored by Taco Bill.
Going to Japan for the first time in March.
Any recommendations for dealing with jet lag?
You know, honestly, I don't have jet lag really going over
there.
I only have jet lag when I come back home.
But my recommendation is on the plane, if it's nighttime in
Japan, sleep on the plane.
If it's daytime in Japan, stay awake as long as you possibly
can.
Just try to match the schedule on the plane.
It's like my biggest advice.
Yeah, yeah.
Some people will just like sleep the whole plane ride.
No, that is amateur tactics.
Don't do that.
I know it's tempting because you're like, I just want to, I
just want to get the plane ride over with.
No!
You must stay awake if you have to.
Blending Minto for Baha Blast.
Is it worth it?
It's always worth it.
I can never sleep on the plane.
I'm one of those like really, I'm one of those really
embarrassing type of sleepers on the plane.
Beef or chicken.
And one of those embarrassing sleepers where like my head
like just starts going forward and then I have to yank
myself up in my sleep.
No, well, thank you so much for that Tony gets it.
Thank you.
It's the only way to catch up on sleep.
I'm telling you though.
You have to.
Same?
Oh my gosh.
You're just like me?
Did anyone keep the windows open?
Not this past time, luckily.
You have a half-donut neck thing?
I do, and I always forget it.
I push the sides of my head rest in, so it locks my head in
place.
See, I do that too, but that doesn't help me from going
forward.
I can, like, rest my head on the side a little bit, but then
I just slowly...
I slowly start to slump over.
And then when I realize I'm...
I wonder what I look like to people next to me.
Because I'm probably like halfway keeled over.
And then I just suddenly go like...
Like I'm a vampire rising from the dead.
Andre goes like so much!
For the Torigata, thank you!
was my big old heavy head yeah i just weighs a ton and slips
forward had too heavy with dreams of idols in metal gear
yeah but yeah oh yeah but yeah today oh you know though i
was gonna start the game but you know i did want to mention
something last on my plane last time i started a show that
i've never watched before and some of you guys are probably
gonna be like
i started watching breaking bad
when are you going to unalive us shortly ducky thank you for
the fact that yeah i've never seen literally i had never
seen a single episode of breaking bad i even i got to the
scene where she was like um my name's something yo uh wife
of walter yo i saw that scene scarlet white yo of skyler
skyler
i'm also going to japan for the first time in may any
certified minto spots to visit
Moss burger
Soaplands I'm not allowed in those Because I'm a lady They
don't allow ladies Which is so sad I'm so curious what goes
on in there Pyrobug Thank you so much for the time Hey And
I'd rather not Thank you so much for the time Thank you both
so much Thank you Rory welcome back That's evil What's evil
What's evil Okay I don't think it's that they don't allow
foreigners Because I knew someone that would go But they
don't allow Girls Why not?
Why can't I have my body Scrubbed down by a lady?
He's saying there's no Taco Bell in Japan?
There is!
There's a Taco Bell in Shibuya But I've never...
And I think there's also in a Tokyo Dome City But I've never
been to them I just remember seeing them and being like,
Wow, Taco Bell!
Nice hot.
Thanks!
Yeah, there's a couple Taco Bells around.
They can't clean off the ectoplasm.
No, all you have to do is use an oil-based soap.
I promise.
Can I get an early happy birthday since you'll be collabing
on the group channel tomorrow?
Smokey!
Happy birthday!
How'd you know that?
How did you know that tomorrow I'll be collabing with the
Densetsu girls on the Densetsu.exe group channel?
How did you do that?
It's in their schedules.
Oh.
I'm almost done with my schedule, you guys.
Sorry, I clicked out of the stream.
I'm just trying to figure out what to do on Sunday, Sunday,
Sunday.
Yeah.
I'm almost done.
figuring it out.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out what to do on Sunday.
I was going to do something.
I was going to do a karaoke, but then I was like, Friday and
Saturday I will be singing and I'm worried that if I'm
singing Friday, Saturday, then my voice will not be good for
Sunday.
So, I don't know yet.
I don't know yet.
Take a day off.
Maybe.
Well, no.
I don't know how much I'll be able to stream while I'm at
holiday Matsuri so I'm like
you know but my I've just I'm so I'm so tired of travel I'm
so tired of traveling um I have a pretty I will explain it I
will be I'm going to holiday Matsuri then February I have
some small travel March I have another Japan trip April May
are wait April is currently free oh January is free February
I travel small March Japan trip April free.
May, I'm moving.
It's so...
Oh, I don't want to travel anymore.
So busy.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
It's halfway into the year already.
I know!
You're telling me!
And then after I move I have
I'm traveling
traveling July June?
July?
I think maybe both June and July and then after that I have
no travel plan and I'm like you know what I don't want to go
anywhere yeah maybe august i don't know six months out i
know just thinking about it tires me out thinking about it
tires me out june july is con time well i don't remember
hold on wait wait what's that oh gosh Sorry, I click out of
the game.
That's why you don't hear it anymore.
Oh, oh,
okay.
Wait, please don't have sound.
When is this?
When are you?
I can't say the event.
Uh...
Why doesn't your website say when you are?
What's your date?
When are we?
I don't know.
I love the redacted event.
I'm just putting together my own calendar right now.
I'm like, hold on, everybody.
Let me put hold of the stream so that I can do my own
personal...
my my booking my let's see when why does nobody ever have a
date oh i think it's august july i don't know i don't know
anymore whatever it doesn't matter i love scheduling yeah
okay um this game last report oh my gosh It's been on my
radar for like months now.
I've been wanting to play it because the aesthetic seems so
neat.
It seems pretty short and pretty spooky.
So I'm just like, I just wanted to try it.
And it's pretty good, yeah.
I don't think it's roguelike.
I think it's actually quite story-based.
Yeah, thank you for the vibe.
Thank you.
I don't remember how I found it.
I just sometimes go through, like, Steam.
But it keeps popping up for me, and I keep wanting to play
it.
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
I keep getting this game on TikTok that, like, looks so
scary.
But it is a Roblox game.
But it doesn't look like Roblox.
I kind of want to try it.
It's like Schwarma Simulator or something.
And you have to not sell food to the anomalies and it gets
scary.
Roblox is scary.
Yeah, Roblox is a horror game.
Sorry.
Content warning, Roblox.
I'm so sorry.
I don't remember what it's called.
Camilla was playing it yesterday.
Yeah, I think it's like the quote-unquote streamer game at
the moment.
But yeah.
Okay, I watched someone play that.
It looks so fun, does it?
It looks so spooky to me.
But let's play Last Report.
I hope it's not my last report.
I'm retiring.
Tomorrow's my last day.
The goal of all life is death.
Death.
10.34 PM.
Bold.
Whoa.
Watch out, buddy.
I might have to like adjust where I am.
I don't know how the UI of this game is.
National Park Among Green Trees.
That's what the that's what the park is.
called time to go night shift reporting in i've just arrived
and starting my shift
oh sorry there's no game audio i'm so sorry luckily there
was no like don't music or anything it was just kind of i'm
so sorry you hear it now oh i didn't read it no it's too
fast what did it say I've already messed up.
What do we got going on here?
Do I turn on the computer?
Oh, let's not do that.
Let's turn on the light.
There we go.
What is this?
I said good luck.
I said read management.
Read guidebook.
Among green trees.
As opposed to red trees.
Blue trees.
trees, yellow trees, orange trees, pink trees, purple trees.
Among.
Welcome to the National Park Staff Handbook.
This guide will help you navigate your role as a park worker
with key information on park rules, safety, and work
instructions.
That already sounds kind of spooky.
destruction yeah let me one second I'm just gonna scooch
over right there protect the the parks flora and fauna do
not cut damage or remove plants or trees dispose of trash
properly to illegal fishing I hope my hat's okay yeah
protect fauna at all costs fishing is prohibited except and
clearly marked areas protect aquatic ecosystems and wildlife
three flying drones drones are not allowed in the park they
disturb wildlife disrupt tranquility and pose safety risks
yeah hide my hat my hat for illegal hunting hunting or
harming animals is strictly prohibited the park is a
wildlife sanctuary five illegal campfires campfires are
allowed only in designated pits to ensure safety and protect
the environment six illegal parking.
Oh my gosh.
I thought this was a free country.
Park vehicles only in designated areas.
Unauthorized parking can harm the environment and block
access.
7.
Restricted area entry.
Restricted area.
Authorized access only.
Unauthorized entry risks safety and disruption.
Free illegal parking.
I can't even park my car on the side of the road!
Example camera report as a night ranger you review verify
and upload reports captured by our park wide camera system
if a report is unclear poorly formatted outdated or
incorrect you must flag it what's today each report has
number number date sector image description work to it's the
ninth oh thank you today is today it's Tuesday in the report
submission procedure take a report from the paper stack and
verify its accuracy upload to computer oh sorry unless the
report is damaged okay if the image matches the description
select the correct category and click click submit it is the
music getting weird.
Surely they wouldn't start anything until I've done reading
the tutorial, right?
If people trespass after dark, the freaky ghost will get
them.
What music?
You guys don't hear the ambience, so I need to turn it up.
Can you hear that?
If the image doesn't match, select image does not match the
description and click submit.
Here, it now.
Okay, cool.
If a report is damaged, destroy it using the Shredder.
If the report is over two weeks old, select report.
Wait a minute.
Select report is outdated and submit.
The report is old.
Uh.
Any report before January 10th is outdated.
After submitting pass the human test to complete the human
test?
Yes Oh my gosh Remember if you watched my stream yesterday I
talked about like this path By the real con that we were
hiking We thought it was just like a tiny little trail But
it ended up becoming like a crazy hiking path One of our
friends decided to like run up the path To see if there was
an opening To easily get back to the real con Instead of
hiking all the way back to the road And we were like joking
that they were taken over by a skinwalker and that they
would be like, Hello, it is I.
You're a very human friend.
Unfortunately, no Nancy Drew, no robot cats, no ghosts in
the onsen.
So sad.
What is your ghostly wisdom of the day?
is a noisy one.
Yeah, no-no-no-grams.
That's the worst part, right?
Actually, I do have no-no-grams on my phone.
So I did play no-no-grams a little bit.
I had to!
It's like part of the atmosphere.
After I've completed the human test, you can check your
stats in the review track app.
The app refreshes periodically.
Oh!
Someone's at the door.
oh it's a man hey look who's here how's work going I haven't
even turned on my computer yet so that's what coming back
from vacation looks like how was it tell me everything
arrived it's in time for cute y'all in Tescaru it's John
last report he's the one oh where to begin sand in my shoes
blazing heat those two weeks flew by fast wait this is just
like me I also was gone for two weeks and but I have no sand
in my shoes I think but I also scary child is blocking the
text oh let's see where can I put you guys we'll move you
like right here.
Moving down a bit.
We'll see if I have to throw you over to the left side.
The family loved it and that's what mattered most to me.
It was amazing, but all good things.
Come to an end.
Welcome back to reality.
I'm manhandling you by your super grabbable hips.
Yeah.
I'd love for my biggest worry to be the heat.
Anyway, I stopped by because I've got some news.
Is it a raise?
Oh, no.
Come on.
Haven't you just gotten back from vacation?
This is reality.
No raises and there won't be any.
But they started replacing electric poles in the park
yesterday and every now and then the power goes out.
I don't like that.
So some Sometimes the lights flicker, but that's nothing
new, since things here rarely work properly.
Oh, and we're down to walkie-talkies since calls don't go
through.
There's still no signal.
They still haven't fixed it?
Jeez, it's been, what, at least three weeks since we
reported it?
So if the power goes out, just wait a bit, and everything
should come back to normal.
Oh, what was that?
Oh, and for my best buddy, here's a freshly brewed coffee
strainer.
from the store to wake you up nice thanks so what do you
need me to do this time haha you know me too well man if
it's putting new maps up in the info boards you're going to
have to bring me like 20 of those coffees 20 no no a new guy
starting his first shift today and I need you to give him
the keys to his cabin I'm out on patrol and don't feel like
coming all the way back without a car hand over the keys
great i'm off then i need to finish up this patrol and
time's ticking welcome back man and if you get stuck on
anything remember to check the guidebook i'd probably forget
a ton after a vacation like yours thanks oh whoa wait what
was that what did i just uh important thing here you go bro
i saw the way that i knew what it said was because behind
the game screen, I can see my stream, and I saw the text
just come up really fast.
Here you go, bro.
You guys think John is going to survive the night?
A souvenir for my vacation.
Oh, shit, man.
Now this is...
Wow, an effing gift.
Not some fridge magnet.
Thanks.
out at the next barbecue.
Oh, John is not gonna make it.
John?
John is not gonna make it and our newly hired friend is not
gonna make it.
Sounds good, but now if you don't mind, all right, all
right, I'm out.
I can see the pile of reports on your desk.
He said, he hinted at a future event.
There's no way.
There's no way he'll make it.
Catch you later, alligator.
Mm-hmm.
Later.
Crocodile.
Wait.
Yeah, shut it.
Shut the door.
I should start working.
The stack of reports is pretty large.
Wait, I need to finish reading this last part, though.
Digital tools.
As a park employee, your computer is a vital tool for
monitoring and managing daily operations.
Hold the escape key to open the game menu.
Report app.
Weather app.
Park watch app.
Report track app.
Wait, so submit park incident reports.
View real-time park weather.
Interactive map showing sector status.
Verify report accuracy.
What is this?
I guess this is the radio?
Oh my god.
Why do they cover up the whole screen when he does that?
I wonder what the weather's like today.
Rainy.
Until three eight...
Wait, is this like a five nights of Freddy's situation?
Do I have to last until 3 a.m?
A cupa.
What time is it now?
This computer doesn't have a time.
I have no clock.
All right, let's see what we got.
Report the files, review.
Okay, documents.
Trip with John!
Wait, what are these?
Oh, What the...
What is this called?
20 and 24, 1?
20, 24, 2?
20, 24, 3?
Oh, dang, we're the life of the party!
What computer doesn't tell the time?
I know, right?
How am I supposed to know when my shift is over?
Trip with John, let's see.
Ah...
Okay!
Taking a picture of the dogs he is bald that is one shiny
head
keep folder oh it's password protected info folder january
5th january 5th 2024 the park administration announces the
early end of patrols and night shifts on january 16th and
17th due to park maintenance work all supervisors are
required to inform night shift and patrol employees that
their shifts will end two hours earlier.
Every employee must check out from the park no later.
Ah, so we do end at 3 a.m.
How do I know what time it is?
Anything going on in the park watch?
Okay, everybody's... Oh, sorry.
Everything's alive, I guess.
Wait, what the hell is that?
Oh, that's a tree.
Oh, gosh, my head's in the way.
Okay, hold on.
hmm maybe i'm like here maybe that would be best we fishing
the night maybe let's see if that works oh you still can't
see it fully go to the left i think so wait i'm never over
here okay i'm scared over here you guys join me you guys
join me on the left sorry i it said that I didn't know the
UI of the game, so I might have to throw you guys around a
little bit.
This is fine.
Everything's fine.
Okay.
There we go.
Sorry, I'm adjusting things on my computer and now...
Okay, there we go.
See, I thought this was a thing, but it's a tree.
Okay.
Let's look at our first report!
Hold right mouse button on report to drag it.
Okay, it said anything before January 10th, right?
Okay.
42G.
Two boats are spotted on Lake C-17 with fishermen on board
casting their lines into no fishing zone.
So what, I report this?
Phoebe!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Hold on, I'm trying to figure out...
I just started this game, I'm trying to figure out what to
do.
If a report is unclear or formatted, you must flag it.
It said only two boats, but I saw three.
Thank you for all the gifted, you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where did it go to?
Oh, here?
Oh, okay, okay, wait.
It says two.
Oh, there are...
I was thinking of two people.
There are two boats.
One boat, two boat.
But this boat has two people.
So this is fine, then.
It's not outdated at all.
So I just leave it, I guess.
Thank you guys so much for all the gift.
Thank you.
figure out the game and concentrate before I...
Oh, here we go.
Okay, I see.
You report it for...
Oh, okay.
Illegal fishing.
Ah, I see, I see.
Okay, I did not notice this drop down.
Okay.
Illegal fishing.
Submit.
Which path?
Oh, this is the human test.
This goes to the cabin.
Oh, I submitted my first report.
I see, I see, I see.
Thank you guys, roll the gift, Sid!
Thank you!
Okay.
Two hunters are spotted in the I-16.
This is wrong.
Because the zone is incorrect.
Carrying a deer between them to make a makeshift stretcher.
So this is wrong.
Image or sector doesn't match description.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Foggy lake, a boat, two people.
Was the photo taken up?
Chris!
Oh my gosh.
Ace Attorney moment?
Did you guys see that?
That they were like, We want to make Mega Man, Ace Attorney,
and Devil May Cry bigger IPs or whatever?
Kind of crazy.
Submit.
Catch the poacher.
Which kind of surprised me.
I always thought that Mega Man was already like a really
popular IP name, you know?
I don't know.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you, Warden.
Thank you.
Mega Man is alive.
I guess...
What?
What was that one game that the creator made that was like
a...
What's the word?
That was, uh...
Kickstarted Mighty Number 9!
I feel like ever since then it was kind of like...
You know?
Oh, creepy!
Oh, whoa!
I wish I could...
I wish there was like...
I feel like this is a little, um...
What's the word?
Difficult of a...
Way to do this.
Just because it's like...
It doesn't feel very streamlined.
I don't know.
It's fine.
All images with deer.
Oh my gosh.
I hate human tests.
What is this?
Review track.
Oh, I got one wrong!
No way!
Wait, my shift ends up...
No, no, my shift ends at 3.
The report tracker updates itself periodically.
Wait, I got it wrong?
There's another one, though.
What am I supposed to do with this?
Let me...
Let me check the...
Let me check the guidebook.
Uh-oh.
Wait, you must flag it.
Oh, here we go.
Um...
Damaged.
Oh, destroy it using the...
Oh!
Wait, I already put it in.
Wait, take it out?
Wait.
Wait, I messed up.
Wait, no!
I
didn't realize that once I put it in.
Oh, no.
What do I do?
It won't let me drag it.
Wait, maybe...
Oh, no.
It won't let me put it in the bin.
gonna get i'm gonna take the how does it scan so quickly is
it still the top of your pile no and i can't like right
click it from here either oh that sucks i messed up
let me delete it please
oh alt f4
Maybe if I open it...
Ah!
Oh, uh...
Oh, gosh.
Into the pile!
Into the bin.
Into the bin with a yee.
Okay, never mind.
Uh, I think I'm just gonna have to take the L, everybody.
Hi!
All the trash into the bin.
I...
Uh, there...
Oh.
That must be the new guy John was talking about.
Yeah?
Are you the new guy?
Henry?
Oh, I'm sorry to bother you.
I'm Henry, the new guy.
Hi, Henry.
Nice to meet you.
John mentioned you dropped by for the keys to your cabin.
Oh, I thanks a lot.
You know, it's not every day we see someone new joining the
night shift.
It's great to have you here.
If you have any questions, feel free to ask.
Thanks, John actually showed me everything yesterday and
went over the rules.
I also heard this park is a great reputation.
Why is he British?
I don't know.
Ask him!
Why?
He came from England!
Is that so strange?
Is that so weird?
He's British?
Oh, sorry.
I accidentally clicked out of the game.
Yes.
Ponstit Awards and Stellar Reviews.
Pretty impressive accomplishments.
That's true.
We do our best to live up to that reputation.
That's good to you.
What's he doing?
He's so shy.
Have you worked in a park before?
Is this your first time?
Oh, I blimey, I've never even been to the United States of
America.
I've never worked in a park, let alone on a night shift.
I took this job because it pays well, and I just finished
moving.
See, he moves!
They're from England.
He would call it the colonies.
Oh, my bad.
Flink Peek.
Oh, really?
I haven't heard about them paying a lot.
What brings you to such a remote place?
Flink Peek is a small town.
Honestly, I'm not even show myself.
My wife and I moved here because we wanted a break.
Ten years in the corporate world really wore me down.
Life here seems so peaceful.
No rush.
Just better.
And honestly, if I'd stayed there, my health would have
taken a serious toll.
I get that.
Anyway, I should stop chatting and get to my cabin.
Get my cabin set up before it gets too late.
Henry, good luck with the job.
I hope you'll be a Great partner.
Flink, pink, flink, flink, flink, flink, flink, I can't say
this name.
I don't know why, but I love the feel of pixel art horror
games.
Me too!
Flink, flink, flink, flink, flink, flink might be out in the
middle of nowhere, but like you said, there's no rush here,
and the nature around us is the best part.
Exactly.
Thanks for the chat.
Once I've got some free time, I'll definitely drop by Dan
for a cup of...
See you around!
See you, Henry, and remember to enjoy the nature around you.
Stop being such a weirdo.
Forcing a British accent.
Flink Pink is my favorite K-pop group.
Oh, I said something about corporate life.
I missed it.
Oh well.
Uh, okay.
This guy, bad, shredder.
Yeah!
A hunter is captured on camera in the Q27 Forest Zone,
standing over a freshly killed deer.
The hunter is holding a rifle and appears to be inspecting
the deer.
January 4th!
Okay, so this is an old guy.
This is an old report.
Report outdated.
To the cabin.
Flink.
Wait, didn't I get it right?
Oh yeah, I got one wrong.
My accuracy?
No.
Come on, I need the power to get anything done.
Come on.
I'm scared.
Someone's calling.
I should pick up.
Oh, hell.
This is Caroline.
Do you copy?
Over.
I copy you, Caroline.
Hey, I'm calling because...
I'm calling to say goodbye!
Caroline, I just met you just now!
I'm sorry.
I didn't even have time to stop by and talk.
Goodbyes like this suck, and I feel bad for ending things
this way.
I just had.
Caroline, I understand.
You don't need to explain yourself.
Wait, what's going on?
Hey, I don't think this is the end.
You can still reach out or drop by anytime.
I didn't mean it's the end.
It's just...
So you got the job?
Yes, I did.
That's great.
That's excellent.
You should go into this...
You should go into this science.
Oh my god, she's going into science.
I don't think this is my wife.
How's this called?
Park Science Laboratory Researcher.
Thank you for the Superchild!
Yes, that's a good opportunity for you and your future.
She's a scientist.
Women in STEM!
I know, and I'm a little scared.
But it will be fine, right?
Oh my god, Caroline's not gonna make it either.
Caroline just got a new job.
Henry just got a new job.
Uh, John is looking forward to the barbecue.
Nobody's making it out alive.
Of course it will be fine.
I'm telling you.
I just wanted to tell you that it was a pleasure working
with you.
I could always count on you.
And this park has one of the best employees in you.
Aw.
Okay, okay, enough.
Hey, I have a request.
Yes?
In your free time, make me a robot that can do my job for
me.
No, wait, too real.
It's called Chat GPT.
Haha,
as soon as I start making robots, I'll bring one to you.
Great, I've got to get back to work.
Take care out there, Caroline, and good luck.
Thanks.
For all these years of working together, I promise I'll
visit your park more often.
But for now, over and out!
Over and out!
I'm sure she'll do great at the new job.
Oh, so there's like a little counter, okay.
Oh, I could just call anybody!
Douglas?
Who was...
Wait.
John!
Hey, hey, how's it going?
It is for horror movie game reasons that I make sure nothing
positive is happening in my life when we're heading to work.
Eh, alright.
Same as always.
Boring.
Still got a bit more trail to cover.
Gotta say it felt better during a better being on vacation.
Yeah, of course it would Oh, come on Were there always this
many reports to process?
Be glad you're not walking around in the rain.
Oh, and I meant to call you.
Did you see the email from management?
They're gathering people to represent the park at the Colo
town fair the the colon town All about digestive health
that's where the colon was born free trip and a bonus plus
you know how chill those events are that place smells like
ass oh last time we barely even had to stay at the booth
sounds tempting not gonna lie I'll be at HQ tomorrow when I
finish my shift oh wait this is John Sorry.
Want me to sign you up too?
Yeah, I'm in.
Do it.
Last time was awesome.
Now that's what I like to hear.
Alright, I'm wrapping up.
Got it.
Over and out.
Let's get back to work now.
A lone fisherman is spotted.
A boat, Lake C-17, January 12th.
Illegally fishing in a protected zone.
Okay, seems good to me.
Illegal fishing...
Summit!
Uh, poacher.
Oh, they're dating, you think so?
I'm...
I'm scared of when something scary is gonna happen, you know
what I mean?
I'm scared of when something scary is gonna happen!
Oh, it's a... I was like, oh my gosh, UFO!
January 19th, the drone is captured on H-34.
It's buzzing noise disrupting the peaceful surroundings of
the park.
four flying drones images with deer oh my gosh is that
that's deer what was that oh my report summary updated wait
I think someone's calling me hello hey can you hear me hello
boom hey I can hear you over finally I managed to get the
signal up do you have access to the computer yeah what do
you need i'm currently repairing the signal tower in sector
a22 i need to check if the system is showing the correct
status now can you check park watch and let me know the
status of sector a22 all right checking now standing by over
okay check the status park watch a22 uh f50 a22 under repair
something's still not right okay
the sound of the rain sounds a little different all of a
sudden right on daddy thanks for the gifted park ranger
hello you there over yeah i checked but the system still
shows under repair damn all right i think i see where the
problem might be i'll give it another shot tough one not
really but the heavy rain and wind aren't helping This whole
tower is shaken, but I'll manage.
Someone's got to do it, right?
Sure that.
Stay safe up there.
I'll check in with you after I give it another try.
Thanks for now.
Over and out.
Alright, let's check our review track.
We're doing well.
Ah!
Look at that!
78% accuracy.
Let's go.
Oh, my god.
Oh, I thought it was in a hole.
So he's dead?
No!
The sectors are wrong.
I already see it.
Yes, this.
I'm human.
Why does he look so upset by that?
What's that sound?
Oh, okay.
I don't recognize the sound of the computer anymore.
Okay.
The kids be partying.
Three people are sitting on top of an electrical shed inside
a fenced-off area near 822.
Okay.
I wonder how many I have to get through.
Let's see.
Restricted area entry.
Plant a tree.
What?
Well, these tests are getting insane.
Oh, someone's calling?
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Oh, sorry.
I thought the power just went out outside.
It's just the text bar.
I was like, wait a second.
Where'd the sudden go?
It does sound like the sticky key sound, doesn't it?
Hey, I hear you, over.
Great, the signal's getting stronger.
You have access to the computer?
I need to check the sector status.
Yeah, I'm online.
The tower should be fully operational now.
Everything looks good on my end.
Can you check Park Watch and confirm the status of sector
A22?
Checking now.
Standing by.
Over.
All right, A22, baby.
Aha!
He did it!
The status is all good.
All right, let's go.
Hello, you there?
Over.
Yeah, I checked.
Everything's green.
Status is safe.
We're gonna, like, hear him fall to his death or something.
Or get... He's gonna be like, What is happening?
Don't come any closer.
And then...
Status.
I mean, not, sorry.
Static.
Silence.
I combine static and silence.
And I have
to go.
Good night, Minto.
Good night, Brandon.
Oh my gosh, status.
That's exactly what I wanted to hear.
Nice work.
Thanks.
It took some effort, but it's all good.
Now time to head down.
Oh my god, here it comes.
Sounds good.
Appreciate you checking the status.
Status.
Yeah, we're blaming the jet lag.
We're blaming the jet lag.
Gotta run.
It's crazy windy up here.
Over and out.
over and out.
Nah, he's fine.
Person is captured on camera illegally cutting down a tree.
He just wants to be Johnny Appleseed.
Several stumps from previously cut trees are visible.
Oh my gosh, he's in menace.
January 12th.
C17, okay.
This is all good.
Gorsh.
He did...
Uh...
Wait, uh...
Environmental destruction!
To the cabin?
This one.
Serial lumberjack.
What if he's just trying to build a log cabin?
Woohoo!
Our accuracy is going up, up, up.
We're going up, up, up!
I'm gonna take a sip of coffee.
I'm scared.
Okay, everything's fine.
For now.
Illegal campfire.
F-50 trail.
F-50.
January 5th.
This one's outdated.
It was the 10th, right?
January 10th.
Right?
You mean Paul Bunyan.
Appleseed planted trees.
Well, what if Johnny Appleseed wanted to become evil?
What's that sound?
You guys hear that?
The evil lore, Axe.
Yeah, not even the one slur.
The evil lore.
You guys hear that?
Do I open the door?
Uh, let's have some liquid courage.
Can you check the window?
No.
Oh wait, I can't even do anything.
I'm scared Oh
Who the hell was that?
Definitely not one of the rangers What was he doing down
there?
Um, I should call and tell somebody John John I should try
again later Uh-oh, John is dead
Uh, Doug Who the heck is Doug?
Douglas.
Douglas?
No response.
Did he have a hook hand?
I didn't- Hook hand?
I didn't see.
Henry?
Do you cop- Henry, do you copy?
I hear you loud and clear, over.
I just had a weird situation.
What happened?
Someone was in front of my door, but the moment I opened it,
they ran away.
I assume it wasn't one of the park rangers?
I think not, and that's the worst part.
Who could it have been?
Just a little door scratching.
Yeah, obviously.
Hand hook car door?
Man hook hand car door?
Who was foe?
I just wanted to inform you.
If you see anyone suspicious hanging around.
Hooking around?
Let me know.
Sure.
Over and out.
What about Caroline?
Did she leave already?
Okay.
Let's see what we got here.
Area 16 is a...
Oh, the sectors don't match.
What are they doing, though?
Oh, they're doing drone activity.
Oh, image with deer.
This one's hard.
Knocking isn't that guy from a moment ago?
No, don't answer!
Don't answer!
Henry?
Oh, it's John.
Can you explain something to me?
Why the heck is there a bear trap in front of your cabin
door?
Oh, my gosh!
What?
Are you kidding me?
Do you even realize what that thing could do to someone?
John!
What?
John, I just saw some guy outside a moment ago, but when I
opened the door, he ran off.
It must have been him.
he said the trap are you serious yeah but why and who the
hell is this guy it's a shy of surprise
this guy'll be some messed up psycho no normal person would
set a bear trap in front of a park ranger's cabin we need to
report this someone could have gotten seriously hurt and
that guy is probably still probably still in the park I'll
notify the other rangers to stay sharp, and I'll report it
to management.
We'll catch this asshole.
But admit it.
We've never seen anything like this before.
Yeah, I totally agree.
This is messed up!
I never imagined someone would set a barrier trap in front
of my cabin.
Tell the other rangers to watch out.
I'll handle it.
Leaving the trap with you, though.
I'm not dragging that metal junk around.
Besides, it's your gift, isn't it?
John, alright, I'm out.
If anything comes up, use the walkie-talkie, I'll be on
alert.
Got it.
I don't think you should leave me alone.
I don't think you should be going outside alone.
Where's the bear trap?
Can I set it up in front of my door?
Uh, okay.
the guy who set the bear trap saw an extremely large bear
outside.
If you were in Blue Archive, which school would you be in
and which would be your combat class?
Thanks for bringing so many smiles, Minto.
Thank you!
I would be in Trinity so that I could be next to Koharu.
Yeah.
So you're basically Hanako.
But not really.
Okay, let's keep doing reports.
G19.
Oh, the thing is wrong.
Sector is wrong.
This is like papers, please, almost.
I am human.
How's my report?
Oh my gosh, I'm such a good employee.
Did it say, wait, what did it say?
Aim for efficiency?
Aim for a perfect score.
Oops.
Well that's not happening.
Um...
B75, oh my gosh, who's reporting these?
Getting all the sectors wrong.
Right?
B75, Q27.
Yeah.
Who's getting all these wrong?
Oh, someone's calling me.
Hello?
John!
Can you hear me?
Loud and clear.
Listen, I came across a group of people during my patrol.
The park is closed for the night and they were in the staff
only area.
What, they didn't see like the fenced off area or the signs?
They claim they didn't.
Not the sticky keys.
Just some kids, yeah, troublemakers.
We were just as curious back in the day.
Can't argue with that.
We pulled off worse stunts.
I'll escort them to the exit.
Make sure they don't...
Oh, gosh, I'm so sorry.
I can't stop you hiding, you guys.
Make sure they don't mess around anymore and give them a
motivational speech.
Listen, can you call Douglas?
I tried reaching him, but he's not answering.
Starting to worry about our forest grandpa.
Wait, is Douglas the guy that was...
No, if he's a grandpa, he wouldn't be up on the trees.
Yeah, and I'm sleepy.
We should have finished his shift in an...
An hour ago, right?
Yeah, and he's still not back.
I don't want to keep staying late just because he wants to
wander around the forest again.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, Douglas?
We're going to get spooky messages from Douglas, I think.
I've got things to do.
Beer after work isn't going to drink itself.
Yeah, but you know, there's as many years between him and us
as there are trees in this part.
Oh, damn, okay.
Let's give one thing straight.
jokes to me because you're not really killing it.
Dang.
Oh, John.
Tough crowd.
Alright.
I get it.
He loves this place.
He's attached, but he needs to understand that others are
just trying to do their jobs here.
Though on the other hand...
On the other hand, I could understand his passion for this
force.
Damn.
I wish I could see the woods the way he does.
I kind of want to blow my nose.
One second.
Oh my gosh, I got it.
Do it on stream.
Ah, it was a lot.
Wait, speaking of Koharu, a long, long time ago, I said, a
couple months ago, I said that I ordered a Koharu desk mat
and guess what arrived while I was gone.
Finally!
Yeah!
The one lost in the mail yeah yeah yeah it finally came home
for some context for those who don't know i ordered it like
right before the tariffs happened and uh i don't remember
getting track tracking on it but now that i was looking at
it i got it airmail so i feel like it should have had
tracking but um I bought it in August and it came it came
while I was gone
yay I was like holy cow usually airmail takes like a week
two weeks so I thought for sure it was gone for good I even
went back and checked I was like did I accidentally it by
like boat but no I didn't reading this message you know have
stopped needing to yawn oh my god oh glad to hear you had a
great time in Japan I guess they were the only ghost at the
real con this time at least you can have meow tower for nano
no no no grams yes thank you airship once the boat lands.
Yeah, clearly.
Anyway.
Yeah, I just wanted to let you guys know.
She finally came home.
You're making me yawn too.
Stop saying yawn and I'll stop.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
He never seems bored with his job while me.
Yeah, you always look like you're.
Go on.
Finish that thought.
You sneaky little rat.
Never mind.
Just let him know when he checks in that he needs to head
back.
Got it.
Over and out.
Douglas should have been here a long time ago.
Something's not right.
We're gonna get creepy sounds from Douglas.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, shred!
A pile of discarded tires is visible.
The wrong sector again.
Oh my gosh.
I kind of hope that they include...
Again?
Someone's calling?
Sticky keys?
I hope they include some more, like, anomaly-type things.
Park Ranger!
That's a nice hat.
I had to zoom in to read it.
Thanks for zooming in on my noggin!
What's in Q27?
It keeps coming up in those.
Oh, true!
Hello?
Can anyone hear me?
I need help.
Hello, I can hear you clearly.
Hey, I was on patrol and the weather is really bad.
I was supposed to be on my trail, Q11, but I'm somewhere
else.
I think I'm lost here.
Can you give me the GPS coordinates for the nearest rager
station in Sector Q20?
Q27.
I really enjoyed this game.
Hope you have fun with it.
I'm so welcome back.
Thank you!
Q27.
Of course, stay in place.
I'll check those coordinates for Sector Q27.
on the line sorry i heard something behind me i want to make
sure my cat wait okay first this is my order of operations
when i hear a sound behind me first i make sure it's a cat
if it's not a cat then i make sure if it's a roach you see
i'm in a maid cafe that has been long long abandoned and
therefore and try as I might to keep it clean the spideys
and the roaches still come in and if not a roach I don't
know alright Q27 first of all hold on I have to see how good
of an employee I am we're almost to A plus Park Watch G E H
I F Q27 Okay.
44, 25, 121, 90.
Wait, this also...
Okay.
Only some of them have images.
Meow.
Welcome home, you don't miss you.
Thank you!
Welcome back, Grizzly.
And hi, fructose cord syrup.
Welcome back, too.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yes, I can hear you clearly.
coordinates.
Go ahead.
I just heard what sounded like a meow behind me.
Am I going crazy?
Is the game that immersive?
Okay, I've entered the coordinates into the GPS.
Thanks.
Looks like I'm not far from the station.
I'll head there since the weather is only getting worse and
I'll wait it out.
They click in.
If anything comes up, call in.
Over and out.
Is that a dead deer all torn up?
There's no way a bear could have done this.
A dead deer is seen lying near the edge of the B-75 forest
zone.
Its body is severely torn and mangled.
The wound suggests that it was attacked by a predator.
B-75.
What does this...
January 19th.
What would this report be as?
illegal hunting none of the above maybe maybe none of the
above we don't know if it's illegal hunting I feel
like a bear could have done that illegal bearing the illegal
Wow the wildlife are being illegal Henry hey do you hear me
well I hear you Fine, Henry.
Did something happen?
I just saw a child running down the river at Sector F-50.
Looked about 10 years old at most, and I'm not sure, but I
think they weren't wearing shoes.
Are you sure?
Pretty sure.
I got startled because they ran right at me.
Creepy!
Oh my gosh.
I watched that movie, Weapons on the plane as well.
I've had that as like my visual.
But as soon as they saw me, they started running away.
Weapons?
I thought weapons was fine.
I liked it.
I thought it was pretty good.
It was... I liked the mystery.
It was less scary.
It was pretty fine, though.
I liked it.
Did you chase after them?
Yeah, for a bit until I lost track of where they were
running.
Oh my gosh, I'm just imagining them running with their arms
out, like in weapons.
Hmm, strange.
I've already notified base A5.
They'll handle it.
I just hope that kid gets home safely.
And that they don't wander around the park at night.
It really freaked me out.
Thanks for calling.
I'll inform John.
Sure, over and out.
Over and out.
Oh, strange, he said he saw a kid at this hour.
And barefoot?
Ignoring all the creepy stuff, this game is quite cozy.
Yeah.
John!
I should try again later.
I said that I would inform him, though.
People seen at the edge of the D15 lake throwing bottles.
Oh, that's a bottles.
January 20th.
Dang, litterers!
Uh...
It's not fishing.
What would it be?
Environment?
What about Douglas?
Oh, yeah, we'll call Douglas.
Douglas!
No response.
I don't think Douglas is okay, you guys.
Environmental destruction?
Okay, that's what I was thinking, too.
I am human.
Wait, did I...
Can I get one wrong?
That was right, right?
Okay, good.
90!
Now who could that be?
Take a...
Okay.
Douglas!
Hey there, kid.
Oh my gosh.
Hello, Douglas.
I need to stay here for a while.
Hope that's not a problem.
for you you're always welcome here something happened oh my
gosh we should probably Douglas why we have so many
questions why are you here what are you doing there's a
pretty big bear outside and I'm not about to piss it off I'd
rather wait here until it moves along damn I remember
running into one myself once I was scared out of my mind
especially since it had cubs with it Don't want to mess with
mama bear.
You know what I'm more afraid of than a bear though?
I am more afraid of a moose.
I never wanted to count.
Meese are like real dinosaurs.
A child.
They are giant and they are scary.
My dad once had to climb up a tree to escape a moose.
That was charging at him.
I thought I was seeing a ghost.
Former human.
Maybe.
What if I wasn't human though?
What if I'm like former...
Former crab?
You know?
Mucky moose?
Rocky Road?
Gosh, I wish I had some ice cream.
That's the worst case scenario.
It was probably a mother.
she won't stop at anything oh by the way John's looking for
you you were supposed to finish your patrol a while ago why
haven't you returned yet we all evolve into crabs crab
people crab people walk like crab talk talk like people I
was heading back But then I ran into that bear.
The lights went out.
The rain's coming down harder and harder.
This is it.
This is what?
Now it feels like home.
Douglas is reminded of the war.
I've worked here my whole life.
This park is my home.
This place means everything to me.
In this cabin, it's one of the first ones we ever built in
this park.
Do you think he...
Had his first love here in this cabin?
He's like, that cot.
That's where me and Sally...
Mees are terrifying.
They are!
They're not to be messed with.
I didn't know that.
It's also the cabin where that... Oh!
Oh my gosh, I thought he was about to say it.
Where that unfortunate incident happened.
Wait, is my cabin haunted?
I want so badly to meet a guy like this IRL.
Just so spooky and vague for no reason.
What incident?
You don't know the story?
Wait, he's going to tell me a ghost story?
I guess I'm not surprised.
No one talks about it.
Apparently anyone even remembers.
When was it?
20?
25 years ago?
Thank goodness he didn't say another story.
set of numbers.
Douglas, I know nothing about this.
Well, I'll tell you that.
You should know about the fate of your predecessor.
25 years ago, in this cabin, a worker was found dead.
A very good friend of mine.
Jesus, why have I never heard about this?
So it was 2000.
Yeah, it was exactly 2000.
Can you guys believe that we're almost a six.
I can't believe it.
The disturbing part was that everything about that night was
strange, at least for me.
I remember it clearly.
Walking through the forest, I didn't feel right.
I heard whispers.
And sometimes between the trees, I saw silhouettes that
looked like people.
I'm turning to dust.
You and me both, well, my body is like long lot well it's
probably like congealed I wonder advice if my if I still
have bones hmm everything felt off but when I tried to get
closer to those things they turned out to be bushes or tree
trunks oh my gosh the same thing happened to me I got scared
by tree also like they were just illusions if you were a
crab you never had bones oh my gosh you're so right.
My ectoskeleton.
Yes, but the murder wasn't an illusion.
We found him in this cabin, but the worst part was his
condition.
Douglas, he wasn't mutilated and there were no wounds on
him, but he was dead and his body would occasionally ride
like a snake.
towards the door but it didn't have much strength he was
dead but he moved sometimes whispered I've never seen
anything like it Douglas Douglas shut the hell up right now
what happened next what about the police the detectives the
park authorities back then worse people ran this park the
workers were treated terribly everything was worse then but
the worst part was when the Parks Management found out about
this.
I witnessed him myself.
When they carried his body out, all these people were there,
so many of them.
And suddenly everything disappeared.
Every car drove off, and when I came into the cabin,
everything was... everything was cleaned up.
No traces left behind.
Christ, this is beyond comprehension.
Why didn't you report it anywhere?
I did report it, but it didn't do any good.
On top of that, I also almost lost my job here.
Oh, no, Douglas.
They took everything in an instant.
There was no evidence left.
And what about your friend's family?
I've never seen them since then.
I don't know what happened to them, but I'm afraid those
people might have taken them too.
Maybe even.
Douglas, I'm so sorry about your friend, but this is not the
time.
I'm too scared.
I'm literally...
I'm shivering in my booties.
Yeah, why did he stay at the park?
Don't worry about it.
I'm sorry, I'm not going to do the voice anymore because my
voice.
After all this time, I sometimes wonder if he just died and
I'm making up stories.
Douglas is talking, but no words are coming out.
I should get going.
Sorry if I scared you.
But don't worry.
Nothing like that has ever happened again.
He was a really good person.
I did something like this have to happen to him.
I...
Take care, Douglas.
And come visit me more often, okay?
Oh, sure.
I should get going now.
Thank you for letting me talk to someone about this.
Oh, wait!
The weather!
I've never heard of this.
What the hell else have they been hiding from us?
Well, I guess...
convenient timing that the uh i need some liquid courage
everybody coffee's gone no
good psa to be careful of wildlife even the bucks of my
neighborhood get full of themselves come mating season oh
sad thing is there was no more apocalypse
days to look forward to survive y2k survived 2012 rapture
was last september i thought they they i'm just i'm just
slurping for the fun of it.
I thought they changed the rapture dates.
What is going on here?
Oh, a group of four people.
E40, January 13th.
Filming as one person attempts to break a tree.
He's doing a really good job at that.
Am I crazy?
We'll say environmental destruction.
Plant a tree.
I'm the Laura.
Yeah, it got rescheduled, I think.
A group of visitors.
Swimming in a C-17.
Okay.
What would that be?
Oh, restricted area, right?
Uh, restricted area.
I am human.
Let's say, oh, wait, let's talk to John.
Let's say, let's tell him that we found Douglas.
Hello, we found Douglas.
Douglas.
John, do you copy?
I hear you over.
Don't try to take selfies with bison.
Wait, why?
Do they not like it?
Douglas was here.
He said he's heading back now.
I am the Lorax.
I speak for the trees, and for some effing reason, the trees
speak between the bees.
Well, I guess they could if they...
Is there something outside?
Do you guys see that?
I don't know if it was always like that or not.
I was getting worried about him.
You know what?
He told me a strange story, like someone died here in this
cabin before me.
I know that one, but I wouldn't believe it.
Apparently.
You know it.
Why have you never...
Why have I never heard about it from you?
Douglas made that up.
The guy was actually found dead.
Not in your cabin, but outside on the official trail.
It was in the papers back then.
apparently killed himself by jumping from a high place or
something like that.
I don't remember exactly.
It was...
Sorry, it was near the edge of our park, far from our
sector.
Douglas told me something different.
Can you seriously believe that?
I don't know.
Well, I know I still have a lot of kilometers to cover, so
I'm wrapping this up.
We'll talk about it over a beer sometime.
trap guy.
Have you seen anything?
Has he shown up again?
No, it's been quiet.
Good.
I'm around if anything happens.
Got it.
Over and out.
Oh, it is the wiggling of the trees.
Okay.
I thought it was like, I don't know.
I don't know what I thought.
Like, people standing up trying to do the worm.
That's a dead body!
I need to alert the other rangers!
Uncover the report involving a dead person.
That's the achievement I just got.
Dead body is seen lying next to a campfire.
D-15.
Large wound across the abdomen.
The scene suggests a violent attack.
Um.
What do I...
Uh...
None of the above, maybe?
Plant a tree.
I am the lorebox.
And...
Yeah!
let's go uh hello everybody there's um john there's dead
bodies around signal signals gone oh that's not good wait a
second uh uh douglas
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh yeah who's writing these
reports no response from henry Line?
Liquid courage?
It is close.
Be aware.
What is close?
I didn't mean to turn off my light.
There was something in the window.
I need to alert the others.
Oh, what do I do with this report?
Shreddit?
Oh my gosh.
And we take you!
The bear jammed the cobs.
If we just keep thinking of it as a bear, it's fine.
I think I'll submit it as, like, an error because the
description doesn't match anything.
These dang bears.
Let's see if that was a mistake.
No, it says it's okay.
Hello, everybody.
John.
John, if you don't pick up, I'm going to send your toes to
the entire squadron.
Try again later.
What are you talking about?
Douglas!
I should try again later.
Why is nobody picking up?
Okay.
Oh, not the toes.
Oh my gosh.
More dead bodies.
What is going on here?
Who is reporting these?
Two bodies lie by the lake's edge.
C-17, surrounded by a pool of blood.
That's no good.
Things are ramping up crazy.
Wait.
Was the background always weird like this?
Did I just not notice?
What in the X-Files Twin Peaks is going on?
I don't think so.
What am I supposed to do?
Uh, submit?
Oh, someone's calling.
Hello!
Sticky keys!
Hello, can anyone hear us?
Hello, we need help.
I hear you, Oliver.
Where are you?
Hello, is anyone there?
Hello?
I can't hear anyone clearly.
We have a lot of wounded.
We can't.
I can't hear you.
Wait, what do you mean I can't hear you?
Hey!
Something's going on in this park.
What is going on in this park?
Liquid courage Imagine it like turns into blood or something
That'd be crazy, you know
Oh god Two people impaled on tree branches Surrounded by a
mass of terrifying creatures What do you mean Wait, I don't
see any terrifying creature Oh gosh, I'm scared
Oh my god, I'm scared Oh my god None of the above.
It's just scary.
The ones with the deer.
Deer.
Maybe call the police.
For real, though.
Am I being a good employee?
Yippee!
93% accuracy!
Try John again?
I should try again later.
Again, I'm trying again later.
Signal's gone.
24th January when that report was literally yesterday.
Wait, that's so scary!
I don't mean to alarm anyone, but I think something's going
on in this park!
Something fishy's happening here.
Try Caroline?
Uh...
No response.
They?
Why?
They who?
I see pain.
Pain.
So many hanged bodies.
Bodies on the ground mutilated.
They're suffering so much, please help them!
What the hell is that?
No one's in here!
It's so scary.
I'm afraid to get on my computer.
Weird looking bear.
I'm taking off my jacket.
I was so cold at the start of the stream, and now I'm
sweating, man.
Uh.
What if I open the door?
Oh, he stays.
Okay.
Let him in.
Okay, well, I gotta get on the computer.
Do I still hear him?
Yeah.
Oh, that's scary.
That's eerie.
Oh my
god It's just still going Oh, shred this
Tall figure watches from the edge of it 22 The subject
doesn't move Something holds Hope perhaps Oh, stop
It's so like Stop right there, scum Oh my god Oh my god
Whoa, what's happening?
I didn't mean that...
Oh, the background's like totally different now.
I didn't mean to click on my computer.
E!
Wait, it changed.
It changed.
It killed the guy!
Oh my god.
Wait, that's so freaky.
That's so freaky.
I'm going to try calling everybody again?
Hello?
No response?
Where were you, John, when I needed you?
Signal's gone.
Signal's gone?
John, last report?
Is this why it's our last report?
Try again later.
What the heck is happening here?
I'm gonna be above.
Dear.
Oh my god, that's my door.
That's my door.
My door is open.
Everybody, my door is open.
My door, my door is open.
How many buckets of Ectoplasm have you sorted so far?
Am I a good employee?
Yippee!
Let's just shut that in that guy's face.
Not today, sir.
Excuse me.
Not today!
I have work to do.
And coffee to drink.
Is anybody alive out there?
I'm not interested in your services.
He's like, hey, buddy.
I just wanted to tell you you have really secure windows.
But you might want to lock your door.
Nobody is talking to me.
I feel like trying Caroline because she like quit the job is
not, you know...
Oh my gosh, it's normal!
It's just a drone!
Okay.
They're putting me in a false state of security.
Her wallpaper is still messed up though.
Flying drones!
That's what it was, right?
A drone is captured flying, yeah.
rain of spiders that's what it looks like to me rain of
spiders nothing beats a jet to holiday oh someone's calling
me we've been trying to reach you about your cars extended
warranty hey can you hear me please pick up John yeah John I
hear you what's going on are you seeing the monsters to the
killings yeah I can't even describe them it's terrifying I
keep seeing monsters in the distance I hear other park
rangers screaming, gunshots.
How many park rangers do we have?
Wait, aren't you in a cabin?
No, I couldn't make it to any of the cabins.
They're all too far.
I'm hiding near the rock.
Oh, John.
You're hiding near the rocks?
John.
Oh, John.
I should be safe here.
John, I just want to say before you die...
You have really nice toes.
You don't need a pedicure.
Listen, I've got an important message.
There's something wrong with the reports.
Henry contacted me.
He says that they're changing.
Yeah, yeah, ours changed too.
One of his reports mentioned something about a center.
A heart of the anomaly.
He's still going through the reports, but hasn't found
anything new yet.
You need to submit the reports as soon as you can.
Okay.
There's a chance you might find the center and maybe kill
the anomaly Or at least stop it.
Let's just hope he's John battlefield His name is John dead
guy Imagine he's just like by the way, I never told you my
last name It's dead man walking Static these reports are
terrifying everything around me is weird as hell I don't
know.
Hey, calm down.
It's going to be okay.
Just start submitting the reports.
It's our only hope now.
Do you understand?
Yes.
Whatever happens, it'll be okay.
Right?
His name is John Wick.
Uh-oh.
His dog.
Yeah, it's going to be okay, John.
We'll make it through.
Oh, gosh.
We'll say we.
We need to call for help.
Right, I should.
Uh-oh.
Here it comes.
Oh!
John!
I can't hear!
I can't hear you!
John!
It was so obvious.
Freak!
Pick up!
Oh!
The signal is too weak.
Is that it?
It's the signal?
Douglas, can you hear me?
No.
Try again later.
Let me try it.
Henry, too.
Nothing.
All right, we just gotta do our reports, everybody.
Vehicle parked, C-17.
Over 72 hours abandoned.
January 16th, okay.
John Ordov.
Illegal parking!
these feel these like little mini games feel like the among
us tasks no let's see i
see a death that's my cabin scary uh not me uh shred that
something just entered the cabin oh my gosh did you guys see
it crawling on Oh shoot.
Oh no no.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, where'd it go?
I cut?
Am I gonna die?
Hello?
My flashlight!
.
Guys, I think we're dead.
Another bastard down.
Oh, dang it, Douglas!
Plenty more will follow.
Douglas!
Oh my god.
I'm shaking all over.
He almost killed me.
You have to be careful.
Don't make any noise.
They can hear really well.
These monsters, what the hell is happening?
I can see their silhouettes again.
It's happening all over.
I have to help Henry.
Before it's too late!
I saw him, he's trapped inside a cabin, and two monsters are
trying to break in from the roof.
I still have nine bullets.
He's got nine bullets left.
I try to go through the reports.
They're supposed to help somehow.
That's what I heard, too.
Are you sure you can do this?
You're all alone.
Nine shots.
Enough to...
More than enough.
I spent 40 years shooting and surviving in the...
this damn park.
If I ever die, I'll be right fucking here.
Yeah, Douglas.
Yeah!
Can the power come back on then?
I can't do it.
Oh.
Hello?
I hear you loud and clear.
Good.
Very good.
Know that you're in some serious trouble.
Why?
Who the hell are you?
I've been researching this shit for far too long.
It took everything I had.
Unfortunately for me, there's no way back.
I don't have to, and I won't.
I've got nothing left.
Nothing left to lose.
What are you talking about?
Who are you?
Answer my question!
You've already met.
Not long ago, I'm Doctor.
Sorry.
Oh, he's the guy.
Sorry for the gift I left by your door.
It was you, you son of a bitch.
This is...
Yeah, once again, sorry.
I tried to lure that thing, but it was pointless.
There's something in this park, isn't there?
Monsters, anomalies?
What the hell is going on?
Please, tell me!
It's very complicated.
In short, you're all gonna die there, but...
But I'll try to help you.
Call the police!
Where the hell are you?
Doctor!
I'm already far from here.
Far from that park.
The signal's gonna cut out soon.
Fuck you.
Fuck me!
I just uploaded all my files to your computer!
Files that no one else has!
Files that can bring us closer to solving this mystery!
Why are they so... why are they so mean to each other?
They can help a lot, but they're incomplete.
The reports can show the rest, but it's too complicated.
Give me one second, guys.
I'm gonna...
Oh, I only have...
Wait.
I'm gonna pop in a...
There's a lot of talking.
I'm gonna give myself a little...
Wait.
I'm gonna eat some syrup real quick.
Wait, no.
Actually, sorry.
I have throat spray.
I'll do that in a second.
I should help.
Mm-mm-mm.
The reports can show the rest, but it's too complicated.
There's a recorded video of case 1998, but it's corrupted.
There's a chance to repair it.
Case 1998, that murder in my cabin?
Yes, there are many weird things happening here.
Hi.
If you make it out alive, you'll find me too.
Those files, they're the culmination of my whole existence
and everything that was taken from me.
Ha ha ha ha.
Funny, isn't it?
That these files were my whole life, everything around them?
I wish...
I wish you luck.
Take care and remember.
Wait, listen!
Remember that shit is fast as fuck!
They curse so much in this game.
My goodness.
Hey.
How do I repair the video?
Oh.
This is unreal.
What's happening here in this park?
I...
I would.
Hello!
I guess John is in dire states right now.
I should try again later.
Douglas is going ahead.
Let's check on Henry.
They tend to curse a lot in the trades, do they?
Some liquid courage.
What's my track looking like?
Wait.
Three?
it went wrong?
Oh!
Case 1998.
Oh.
Why'd they make it so spooky looking?
Newspaper news.
Yeah, that's what the newspaper tends to report.
News.
Today's news.
A suicide has occurred.
That's a lie.
The house was wrong, I guess.
I only got to drag it to my computer.
I didn't even get to sort it.
night within the grounds of the among green trees national
park one of the night night shift employees took their own
life during duty according to police reports more details
are expected to be released soon parks management has yet to
comment on the incident we extended our condolences to the
family and loved ones this
game is so in serious I it's the entity
What is this one?
20, 34, 16.
Drones?
What is that?
Ah, ayayayayayay.
Ayayayyay.
That PNG.
What are these?
Notes.
Emily photo.
Oh, is she the little kid?
Emily description.
Emily was last seen on January 2nd.
It's worth noting that during the events of the of 1998, a
young girl named Emily was also reportedly seen.
I suspect she is not human, but rather one of the creatures
or a manifestation.
Be careful, she appears with a knife in some of the photos.
A drawing likely made by Emily was found in the cabin.
Pikachu!
Okay.
Little stick man on top of some bodies.
Page one.
The tree?
There's a... There's a safe under... Oh, there's treasure!
Apparently this game has multiple endings.
Then I saw it, the creature featured in the...
Creat- Feet- Feet-
Mm-hmm.
Do you know?
Oh, why do you do this to me?
when I'm jet-locked.
Hold on, let me try.
I mean, revenge, revenge, revenge.
The creature featured in the feature featuring the creature.
Yeah.
Just like the reports create anomalies and allow us to see
things, the computer files also seem to reveal a lot.
There are many hidden files.
Reading them isn't easy.
Some can be decrypted, which could bring me closer to
solving this mystery.
But so far, I haven't been able to crack a single one.
Sometimes what's most hidden is right in front of you.
I have no idea how that's supposed to help.
This is...
Sorry.
This is breaking me down physically.
Solving one piece!
Only opens the door to three more.
The reports can even lead you astray from the right path.
Everything is so damn messed up!
Nicely done, thank you!
And then I should access a file that clearly pointed to a
key.
C underscore 0 4.
Unfortunately, it's corrupted.
It can be decrypted, but how?
Oh my gosh, I'm hacking.
Hacksores?
What did, that was page, no.
That was weird notes file.
Then weird notes file 3.
I can't take this anymore.
Someone help me.
Help me.
Help.
I don't want to see any more of this.
That was terrifying.
Everything is starting to make sense.
I can't keep writing.
He's alive!
Uh, those were notes, right?
and then okay this is encrypted does that mean i have 49
chances left
no newspaper oh yeah we saw that one
there's also our own documents like this visitor stats
oh yeah i didn't finish reading these january 11th the
parking administration reminds all employees about the
upcoming meeting regarding the new guidelines for leading
tourist groups.
All employees are required to intend on January 14th at the
main building.
Become familiar familiar.
The park administration announces a scheduled computer
update on January 28th.
All supervisors are required to complete the update by
February 10th.
The park administration announces the beginning of
registration for the trip to Colen Town!
8.008.
It has to be.
Where the park will be represented at this year's fair.
The entire trip is sponsored and fully funded by the park
administration.
Participating employees will receive a one-time salary
bonus.
Cool.
Hope to see you there.
Is that...
Negative...
I'm sorry.
Wait.
It's negative 31 degrees Celsius?
Also, if it were that cold, it would not be raining.
Right.
Am I crazy?
Even like one degree Celsius, I think it would be snowing.
T-shirt weather.
Going with the tea.
Oh, the last captured images are gone.
Oh, wait!
Everything is inactive!
Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh.
Not good.
Uh...
I don't know...
It's right in front of you.
Negative 31C, your frostbite is under 5?
You frostbite it under 5?
It is, that's crazy.
Mido-chan, gambare, o-tukare-sama-de-sta!
E-lai!
Thank you!
Mid, mint highlights my day.
A message from K.
Hi, K!
Thank you!
It's probably in the reports, right?
Oh, this corrupted data.
Corrupted data set.
Trying to see if I find any, see any, like, numbers, but I
don't.
Maybe there's something in the trash.
Could call, but there is not.
we could try 19 yeah let's try 1998
no let's try that though for this maybe oh whoops 19 98
ah is there a 49 anywhere else in your files Trip with John
Info folder 49 I think that's everything Hmm
Hmm Hmm
For now I'm just going to do another report A drone spotted
A wrong sector Hmm
We hear gunshots.
Maybe I should call Douglas.
Douglas, did you copy over?
Copy.
I heard gunshots.
Are you all right?
I killed two of the creatures.
But Henry's gone.
He's not in the cabin.
Maybe he managed to escape.
Wait, how do we know Henry's gone?
gone possible possible i've got a few rounds left i'm
heading to the main building there are more guards there
i'll join them and we'll come back for you and the others
all right i'm too far from hq i'll stay put okay i'll be so
Douglas you copy over
not good not good not good not good tourists are seeing
scaling okay This is the wrong sector.
The sectors don't match.
I'm going to do a couple more before I explore.
Three individuals are seen climbing over a fence in a
restricted area.
The sectors don't match again, though.
Get the information correct.
Or else it's useless to me.
Yay!
where am i all these reports seven-year-old emily was last
seen on january 2nd 2024 near the city park wearing a black
jacket and black backpack if you have any information oh
gosh wait she about to jump scare me not the flake pink she
got danos 555 one two three four five six seven
What do you think this is?
Stop, stop, stop!
Uh, okay, let's look.
With a Slenderman!
Interesting.
She is gonna be right behind here, isn't she?
No?
This is a cute drawing, though.
Liquid Courage.
Okay.
It's cute.
Interesting.
Hmm.
Try the...
Yeah, let's...
What was the...
What was the full phone number if anybody took it, wrote it
down?
I should have written it down, but I did not.
Maybe it's...
Maybe it's been added.
Whoops.
Notes.
Emily.
5-5-5.
4-5.
six blank.
Let's try it.
Ugh.
Five.
Six.
Another number.
No.
Five, three, one, one.
Wait, what?
What's that one?
Please don't spam.
Thank you.
I'm gonna ignore that if it's the actual answer.
Because we haven't found it ourselves yet.
We haven't found it organically yet.
So I'm just gonna ignore that.
Fishing in a non-fishing zone.
Not the illegal fishing.
With deer.
One.
What kind of report is this?
It broke my shredder.
Wait, that's cool.
It looks like...
Oh my gosh.
It looks like the Pokemon card you'd get when you like...
Whoa, whoa!
When you went and saw the...
Wait, can I throw it outside?
No?
When you went to like the Pokemon movie, you got the special
card.
Tences.exe strikes again!
I guess I have to put it on my computer.
Upload virus!
Is that a heart?
Mr. Thomas.
January 24th, 1998.
I assume you have already seen the recordings from Cabin 11
and what transpired there.
I need not personally describe that terror to you.
I simply want to assure you that the matter has been dealt
with.
Nothing of the sort should happen again and everything
should return to normal with a few days yeah the ancient new
card i would also like to clarify that threatening us with
the police in this matter is entirely inappropriate please
be mindful of where and to whom you direct such threats we
have fulfilled our part of the agreement and we are not
afraid of you or any authorities if anyone were to find out
about these events you would be first to be held accountable
the evidence has been removed along with the witnesses as
agreed it was not easy we are awaiting the final transfer.
After which all contact will be severed.
We sincerely hope we have part ways peacefully, Mr. Thomas.
You have a beautiful park.
It would be a shame to lose it.
With respect.
Doctor.
Happy one year of Minky Magic.
Thank you, Ellie.
And Zina, welcome back as well.
Thank you, Bo.
Thank you, thank you.
I liked my wallpaper before.
I liked it.
I like these photos so much.
It was so funny.
I guess maybe I'd check in here to see.
I don't think there's anything like with the numbers.
This didn't really have anything.
Number of incident visitor stuff.
I don't think has.
Anything that I can tell
Four people are off the marked trail Near the H34 ridge
within a restricted entry One of them is climbing a tree
Wait, January 4th So it's an old one
Those pictures will 1,000% change at some point, right?
I feel like they must, right?
Two freshly killed bodies lie scattered among the nearby
bushes.
Torn into gruesome pieces.
I see.
Somebody's birthday?
Screepy.
Wait, it was outdated?
No, it's not.
January 11th.
I am human.
Oh, someone's calling me.
Hey, I'm coming, okay?
I'm on my way to you.
Henry, please tell me you're safe!
Toxic!
Welcome back, thank you!
I'm safe, I have to get to you.
I'm close now.
Wait, what do you mean you have to get to me?
Henry, if you're near a cabin, maybe you should stay there,
okay?
No, I can almost see your cabin.
I'm nearly there.
You're gonna be okay.
Wait, I don't trust Henry.
Henry.
Oh, he could do this.
Are you hurt?
I'm coming.
Answer me, Henry.
No, I'll be there in a moment.
Over and out.
Hey, Henry?
He's injured.
Why is he so desperate to get here?
Oh, I don't trust.
I don't trust.
Douglas?
Help me.
Oh.
Liquid courage.
And I'm doing a good job.
Yeah!
Wait, I got one wrong?
Which one did I get wrong?
Dang it.
This has nothing written.
Should we just leave the door open for him?
Uh...
There is no description.
Or sector.
Sure!
Yeah!
I guess none of the above
Submit that guy to HQ Get him out of here
My scanner is broken Oh Whoa Do you want to look back
Whoa!
There's a hand.
And, uh...
Maybe we can find the...
Another hand!
He's on the computer!
The skeletons control in the computer!
That's cool.
Looks like he's wearing a hat, though.
Like, he was a... What's it called?
Another guy.
Like another park ranger.
I see the sun and I can't tell what that is.
A pine cone?
This is a cool feature.
I like this a lot.
I don't see any codes or anything, though.
Like no numbers.
Oh.
That's so scary.
Oh my.
Oh.
It's not a real file.
Freaky.
Fire is burning.
Illegal fire.
Wait.
I didn't check the date.
Okay, we're good.
And the D15.
Yeah, okay.
I did check that one, but just making sure.
Illegal campfire?
It's so funny that we're still doing our job.
Despite all of this, you know.
Arrest that fire.
Absolutely.
Please, Kiri.
Whoa.
The heart!
Looks like I'm getting close to the heart.
Disgusting.
Cool.
Upload that to the servers.
Whoa.
Interesting.
Let's check our documents real quick.
Oh my god, the children are gone!
Wait, his toes!
Okay, the party is still...
is still bopping.
Is that John?
Wait, is this me and that's John?
Okay, toes are intact.
The toes are intact!
The...
Spooky!
Wait, so I'm bald?
Am I the baldie?
Aw, man.
Small campfire, E40, January 19th.
Dry brush.
Illegal campfire.
Illegal, yeah, illegal campfire.
I don't know if I should open it.
What if it's Douglas?
Douglas would not knock.
Douglas would...
Douglas would just come in.
Douglas would just walk in.
Oh, I have to answer.
Here we go.
No one there.
Ding dong ditch.
Parked E40.
Illegal parking.
I'm human!
Yeah, I wish it was a door dash with more coffee.
That'd be great.
Okay.
Oh, why is it shaking?
What's shaking?
Bacon?
Carolyn, hey hello, are you okay?
You look really pale.
Yeah, I'm fine.
Everything's okay.
you don't look okay are you sure nothing's wrong no i'm just
a bit tired that's all your health really matters you know i
know there's a difference between knowing and actually
taking care of yourself especially when you're working hey i
don't need your lecture caroline you should take some time
off i'm actually leaving for vacation with my family
tomorrow do you think it's us like we're possessed or
something this whole time good you need to rest a bit
Anyway, lucky for you, I'm the one bringing lunch today.
Just for you, you're getting the extra veggie version.
Hey, that's just cruel.
Ha ha ha, it's for your own good.
I'm going to grab it from the car.
I'll be right back.
What do you want to drink?
Let me guess.
Excellent choice.
Vehicle parked.
Just a normal report.
What do I see?
Oh!
There's something written here.
Nineteen- five three!
I think that guy did spoil it.
Five three.
Uh...
I don't know what to- I can't click on it though.
Man.
But I can- I cannot click anywhere actually.
Oh, I can click here.
Okay.
I'm feeling worse and worse.
We're back.
We're back, baby.
Oh, what was this one?
The legal parking?
Yeah.
I'm planting a tree.
And there it goes.
That means 1998 is one of the codes.
I'm pretty sure I tried using that for something else,
though.
Like, uh...
See?
Yeah.
What if it's...
I mean, what if it's 4-9?
Oh, dang it.
Oh my gosh.
I wish there was a...
No.
Can you check the tree now?
I don't even know where the tree is at.
We don't have a camera for anything.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, wait, like the actual tree.
Oh, these pictures.
The tree on your desk.
Oh, no.
I can't.
Yes?
Some!
I'm just trying to use it.
Hmm.
Yeah, Malik, give me a little drawing.
Uh.
What was this again?
Running Stickman.
Got PNG.
Are these more messed up than before?
The party is still on!
The treasure under the tree, yeah.
Oh, whoops, let me open it.
Hello, anybody there?
No answer?
No response?
Henry?
Where was that guy?
Hello.
Wow.
Anything hiding in the guide?
That's a great question.
Oh?
Douglas?
Douglas, are you there?
Help.
Help me.
Who is this?
Where's Douglas?
Douglas is dead?
The monsters got us.
We didn't stand a chance.
Douglas!
How many of you are left?
Where are you?
We shouldn't have gone after you with such a small team
there were only three of us wait that's how we find out he's
gone the others backed out they didn't want to go Douglas
was up front I saw it happen I ran I ran he died because of
me right wait you don't know you ran though you don't know
if he's dead right he didn't die because of you you did the
right thing try to calm down where are you now can you get
to a safe place yes I made it back I'm outside the main
cabin there are too many creatures out there don't come for
me it's but Douglas he wanted to help you I know Douglas is
gonna Douglas is not dead if we if he didn't see him die we
don't know are you able to you're breaking up hello god damn
it mm-hmm let's check the guide that maybe there is some
hints in here hmm Maybe something is also updated.
8, 2, 3, 1!
You guys!
Oh my gosh.
2.
Dang it.
Sorry.
2.
3.
1.
Oh!
Catch that.
Oh, it's a game.
Game!
Catch it, game!
Press Q to start game.
Catch Apple.
right okay oh okay they're like no trash apple catch apple
oh that was close that's my high score gonna be a hundred
this is gonna lead you into a false sense of security wait
so the whole thing that was locked here wasn't even anything
Worthwhile.
The pop is so crisp.
Like if when I do it with a map, my mouth.
Ah!
25!
Oh, I got an achievement.
Score at least 25 points in the computer minigame.
Oh, okay, well.
Oh, we did that.
Douglas sacrificed his life for you to play this game.
Okay.
Gamer!
Thank you, Douglas.
Well, now my curiosity is satiated from that.
But we still need this five, three.
I don't want to follow what that guy said, but.
Heart is almost here.
Let's just keep doing reports for now.
Someone's knocking!
No, I don't want to get, I don't like the knocking.
That's my sector.
Do you think it's Douglas?
I'm sure the answer will show up soon.
Yeah, yeah, I'm sure, I'm sure.
It's me, Goku.
Alright, here we go.
Because it doesn't let you do anything else until you open.
Liquid Courage.
And...
It's...
Henry You need to accept this deal, please He's coming if
you don't accept this deal He'll kill you There's no other
way I see, I see why you came to me What are you talking
about?
See, I was right, you hear it too, don't you?
All over my desk Henry Let me just scoot here him off there.
A whole cup of Henry.
Is there, like, blood on my book now?
That'd be crazy.
Uh.
He made such a mess.
He did.
Deal or no deal?
Okay.
Corpse can move?
Oh, I don't like that.
Wait a second.
Sector 666!
Call Henry.
Good idea.
I should try again later.
Corpse can move.
I don't want to put this in the computer.
Oh, God.
I don't want to dig a tree.
I don't want to plant a tree.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
No, stop, stop, stop it right now.
Holy cow.
Well, corpse did not move.
Oh, sometimes the atmosphere, the game is so goofy
sometimes, and sometimes it's so freaky.
Henry?
No response.
I wonder why.
What did we get?
Something popped up on my...
Oh, it was this, I guess.
this thing yeah I'm human someone's trying to contact me I'm
sorry I clicked this first let's go 92% accuracy hello hey
John I was in the past I spoke with Caroline is this Henry
wait no this is me oh I'm speaking to John wait why am I
calling John sorry I get the yellow text in the white text
confused sometimes.
The reports are getting stranger, but they show I'm getting
close.
There's some kind of heart.
There's hope.
Ah, that's good.
Really good.
Things aren't going so well on my end, though.
What's happening?
Wait, how do we... How are we just so casually talking to
John all of a sudden?
I'm afraid we won't be able to see each other again.
No!
One of the monsters got me.
I can't move because of my wounds.
Where are you?
I'm coming to you!
Just give me your coordinates please don't come another one
just spotted me it's already coming my way what i'm already
dead just find the heart okay i don't want anyone else to
die it's a shame i won't get to see my family again you will
see them where's the monster now it's running right at me
john some of your coordinates now me i'm sorry you don't
want to hear about what's about to happen over and out my
friend john
this can't add like this you hear me john i'll find the
heart before they get to you
two men are fishing wait f50 wrong sector sorry i just got I
just have to do a few more reports before I can, uh...
Get to you, buddy!
Gosh, that one spooked me.
Wait.
John?
Oh!
What's happening?
Oh, shoot.
Henry's gone.
Uh-oh.
Henry, you get your butt back here right now!
Damn, he cleaned up real good, though.
even leave anything.
Now we got a zombie walking around.
Signal's gone.
I think John's gone.
Yeah, the signal is gone from his body.
Dang, Caroline got out just in time.
She was like, by the way, I got a new job.
Peace.
Oh.
This...
We saw this before.
Um...
on the the thing
look closely there's a there's a ah I see it oh wait that's
so cool that's so cool oh you guys I totally got the code
all by myself and not from some bozo spoiling it in chat man
I feel like that would have been such a cool reveal.
It was still a cool reveal though.
1-1!
Yeah!
Code breaker.
Successfully bypass encryption and open the secured folder.
That's the achievement I just got.
Oh, no.
Now we're really fanafing it.
Corrupted data.
Oh.
What is this?
He's taking photos?
Oh, they're taking photos of the body.
Well, trapped in the void...
What?
Wait.
Gathering fragments of what remained, I managed to create
the clock.
Just like the report plans showed.
Apparently, it has the power to bring back everything that
was killed in the park.
I don't know how true that is, but I'm leaving it in
clocklocation.txt.
in case someone shares the same fate as me if anyone finds
this and wants to use the clock warning it will resurrect
everything that was killed not just people for the clock to
work one condition must also be fulfilled afterwards the
last report must be completed this comes at a you've got to
do your paperwork at a price it will unleash upon you
something unimaginably worse than any kind of death wait so
why would I want to do that
Log 1998 Recovered and secured from cabin number 11 The body
of the chosen one Conditioned detailed in separate file 22
reports documenting homicides 11 anomaly Reports Reports are
disappearing Final count may not be accurate Three utility
knives One park ranger issued firearm Four monster corpses
Seven handwritten notes left by the chosen one Three pens
missing walkie talkie still not found The chosen one.
I hate when the eldritch horror makes me file my paperwork
before it inflicts a weight or is the death on me.
Right!
It feeds on the paper.
It feeds on the Excel files.
The walls and desk are scratched.
The chair is broken in three places.
I thought that said umpul.
The umputer is smashed.
It looks like it though, no.
The umputer is smashed with its parts scattered across the
cabin.
Signs of a struggle are clearly visible.
The ceiling is covered in cobwebs and in some areas traces
of monster slime are present.
This is the terrible...
This is such a bad font.
Eurasianally.
The chosen one's body occasionally twitches and mutters
incomprehensible phrases.
So it did do all that.
With the face on his tongue and everything.
Chosen one!
The entire cabin feels alive from the inside.
Entering it induces a strange sensation.
The second half of the cabin is infected by the anomaly.
Further evidence collection is not possible.
What the hell is going on?
Whoa.
2-2-5.
Is that the missing walkie?
Was there another code that we needed?
2-2-5.
I'm coming.
Chosen one.
Wee-wee.
Clock info.
Oh, that's right.
So what do I...
Okay, I'm going to open clock location and see what happens.
look under the sixth wooden plank from the cabin door that's
where the clock is hidden gathering fragments of what
remains I managed to create the clock just like the report
plan showed apparently has the power to bring back
everything that was killed in the park so you bring back
everything that died but you sacrifice yourself that seems
sixth from the door is that what it said
Creepy.
2-2-5.
Should I look for the watch under the floorboards?
Wait, we get a decision!
But what about the... Wait, okay, so I guess this is
where...
Can I save?
No, dang it.
I guess this is where you can either continue towards the
heart and defeat the evil, or you can bring everybody back
and sacrifice yourself
it's rewind time I don't know what if they yeah I think we
should defeat the evil no what prevents a loop from forming
with the watch that's what I'm saying yeah we should defeat
the evil no deal no deal
Parked illegally.
Uh, outdated information.
We're still just doing my work, man.
I'm a slave to the machine.
The heart is almost here.
Here we go, here we go.
Yeah, heart, heart, heart, heart, heart, heart.
Oh.
Was that correct?
Yeah!
Still got a good old rating.
The heart!
The heart.
I did it.
It's time to end this slaughter.
This massacre, once and for all.
So many innocent people are already gone.
It's time to finish this.
It's for you, John!
Henry!
Where to go?
Fascinating.
Don't you think so, William?
Stay away from me!
You monster!
Monster?
You call us monsters because we kill.
But I only kill those who deserve it.
And what the hell did all those innocent people do to
deserve it?
All those bodies, all that blood.
Innocent.
For years, humans have shown no respect for the forests,
destroying nature, polluting everything.
All reports are just a tiny glimpse of the devastation your
kind brings.
You don't see it, do you?
I came to this world and lived in these woods for over
500,000 years.
years 500 years oh my gosh do you know how old this planet
is you've been here for that's like a baby stop acting like
you're the owner of the forest what the hell this guy i'm
gonna say five million at least geez anyway observing and i
realized it's humans who are the true monsters not us they
are parasites that need to be removed imagine it a world
covered in endless forest dark woods growing freely thriving
without humans and what about us the park rangers we protect
the forest they
will fight to save nature are you going to kill them too we
couldn't see you we can't see anything don't lump everyone
together not everyone deserves your justice that is true
which is why I haven't unless you refuse sorry
an offer for you one you can't refuse your friend already
tried to warn you about it which is disappointing i wanted
to present it my
i'm not doing anything for you this is giving like
castlevania you steal men's souls and make them your slaves
someone chose to complete Last report.
And that's my offer.
I'll leave.
And if I don't complete it, will I die?
If you refuse, I can guarantee your death.
Choice is yours.
Question mark?
Why is there a question mark?
Oh my gosh.
Is that the last report?
Guys?
do do we fill out the last report and let him leave i legit
thought the game had voice acting for the monster was like
whoa they left that in didn't do another thing i think we
should do it because it's the name of the game baby save
scum time i wish i imagine there's checkpoints in this game
maybe hopefully But there are multiple endings for sure.
Hmm.
Do it?
Let's do it.
Yes.
Where am I?
Are we in the void?
It's time to do the report.
Ew.
Oh.
Hello.
So unfortunately you managed to arrive.
I had a sliver of hope that you would escape.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Don't worry.
I know you feel strange right now.
You are in the void, the edge of the human world.
Do you think this is the doctor?
And to answer your next question in advance, I am Mendax.
I was human too.
Why can't I feel my body?
Because by entering the void, you are no longer fully alive.
Wait, so I died?
You could say that.
Your body remained in your world, but your mind ended up
here.
Unfortunately, there is no way out without help from someone
in the normal world.
The same thing happened to you?
How long have you been here?
I think 25 years?
This is not that long at all either.
I stopped keeping track.
I hoped you would escape the monster.
But it got you, too.
Wait, do you know Douglas?
Douglas.
Yes, he was a close friend of mine.
Oh!
It's the guy from the cabin.
Is he still alive?
Yes, he told me about your death.
I'm starting to feel sick.
My head's spinning.
It's only temporary.
Everything should stabilize soon.
Soon meaning when?
I can barely speak.
Your body is adjusting.
It's better now.
Hey, look at me.
Oh, he's just a little guy.
Oh, just look at it.
Oh, my gosh, it's animated.
Isn't it beautiful?
Whoa.
Amazing.
The edge of everything good and sadly everything dark.
But don't worry.
Not anymore.
Come with me.
Is that me?
Oh my gosh, I'm skinny legend.
Real monster, how long is the bureaucratic paperwork?
I'll help you cross the void.
Walk with me through this journey.
Wait, suddenly I'm playing journey?
We'll find a way out.
I promise.
Break your promise, break your pinky.
What?
Sticky keys!
The final report has been submitted.
Complete the game.
Wait, that's where the missing walkie-talkie went!
Neat!
Wait, I lied to this ending though.
It was pretty interesting.
Just like some eldritch creature being a weirdo.
What was 225?
I don't know.
There's different endings, obviously, because there's many
choices we didn't do.
I'm gonna see if we can checkpoint back to the clock,
because I want to try that ending, too.
All the sound effects.
Hey, my man is utilizing his resources.
A very young eldritch creature.
Switch on Hum, Rain Moderate, A.Wave, Computer Glitching,
System Notification.
Wait, then that means it really was a Sticky Keys.
Drinking Tea, Slurping, Sipping, and Gulp 3.
Fonts that may have been used Get rid of the one that made
it look like Oompooter.
If you read this, you're awesome.
We're awesome, you guys.
We're awesome.
What a neat little game.
So we came to the void and was like trying to figure his way
out.
Wait, um, wait, what's...
Oh, skip cutscene.
Okay, the cutscene is still happening.
Wee!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
When does it end, though?
Oh, there we go.
Just wait for the song to end.
Let's try and see if we can do the clock ending.
I think that would be fun.
And, uh...
No!
Well, I guess not.
Wait, did I really have to save?
Was there a save feature?
Dang.
Well, it was still fun.
I think the game had some really creepy moments.
Good atmosphere.
I, you know, I enjoy these kind of like atmospheric horror
games.
It's like silly at the same time.
Game really spoke to me.
I too feel as though I've slipped into some sort of
meaningless void when I have to put out paperwork.
Look up the endings.
I guess I could try.
But I feel if you...
Let's see.
The game wasn't very expensive.
Either.
I almost wish I could speedrun.
Sorry, that's the trailer.
If you heard that.
Yeah, it's on sale.
It's even on sale right now for $4.
Like, super inexpensive.
Dang it.
I wish, I wish, I wish that there were...
If I had...
If I had known...
I would have been saving, but also...
I wish when they give you choices, they allow you to do a
save, you know?
Drifter's really fun pixel horror mystery point and click
fully voiced to you.
You should check it out.
Oh, I'll write it down.
Look it out.
Thank you.
Only Mint Phantom would actually the ancient forest demon.
Okay, but he wanted to act all like, I've been here for so
long.
Like, um, 500 years?
Okay.
Buddy, you are, you are, you've seen nothing.
How do you?
Let's see if I can start a new game.
Like how we figure out how to save.
I'm skipping cutscene.
I do always appreciate those kinds of things, though.
Okay, let's see.
Skip, skip, skip.
Ah, um.
How do you save?
Huh.
I don't think you can.
I think maybe it auto saves when you exit the game.
Not as old as Afterlife Minto.
Wait a second.
Where my Google tells me it saves at checkpoints.
No manual saves.
Ah, I see.
Aw, man.
Give me a second.
Let me see if I can find...
Easy video with the other What the other What's it called?
Endings.
What's this game?
Last report All endings
Oh wow Wait Oh These videos are all extremely long Wait what
the heck This one is like last report stories And endings
these videos are like an hour long
there's manly badass hero but even his is two hours almost
two hours 500 years is barely a teenager yeah
huh huh huh i can't obviously i'm not gonna watch an hour's
worth of video yo somebody else's somebody else's stuff so
um if you want to if you want to um see the other endings
you might have to play the game yourself uh yeah oh man
manlies is not the only one manlies is two hours but there's
another one that's like all endings and it's an hour and 11
minutes Most of all of these are like full ending, or like
full game plus ending, I think.
So I'm not going to like sift through the whole thing to
figure out what's what.
That's okay.
I still like the ending we got.
I think it was interesting.
I'm very curious about the clock, though.
What a neat little game.
Hmm.
Minto will save herself from becoming a react channel.
I mean, I've had to do it before in the past, but I don't
like doing it, so I try to avoid it if I can.
Ah, and another to the list.
Yeah!
Another game to my completion list.
Last report.
Let me do that right now.
Nice, nice, nice.
12, 9.
2025.
Last report.
Yeah!
There should be a couple other games that we knock out this
week.
So, cool, cool, cool.
Spoiler right now, there is no difference between the
choices in the last confrontation.
Same stuff aside from being mutilated by the ghoul.
Oh, no way, seriously?
Wait, that's so lame.
Wait, so if I say no, he just mutilates me and I get sent to
the void anyway?
Lame.
So I guess it's really just a big difference between the
clock and between this ending but also i feel like the clock
you also meet a bad fate so i wonder if it also sends you to
the void everything's a lose-lose yeah choice of but an
illusion oh man okay i'm gonna send you guys back over here
where you belong and me too i don't feel i don't feel right
being over I feel uncomfortable but I had fun I hope you
guys did too I thought it was a neat little game I think I
think if they like added more anomaly stuff that happens
that would be really neat even if it's like a game like this
that's less scripted and like you just are doing like you're
filing reports and I also like would want more I would want
this game more different more things to search for in the
reports and more random anomaly stuff that happens in the
background that like more horror things that goes on right
obviously this one is a little more like uh uh linear it's
like a storytelling so but if it's like a rent like a game
like that were ever to be made it would be so much fun for
me please and this that that this kind of combines it with
like the horror elements of like stuff going on in the
background there's definitely some stuff that could be
expanded on yeah but for like a little indie game this was
not bad this was really good i'd say so orgo thank you so
much for the pink remember chosen minto don't be on the side
of bad and wrong don't be badong
Sorry, not sure if evil monster paperwork is badong or just
lame.
Fun, chill, spooky game for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was fun.
Cool, cool, cool.
But I'm gonna end it here.
I'm actually so hungry.
I didn't eat dinner.
I kind of snacked and I was like, I'll be fine.
But now I'm hungry.
So thank you guys.
How many games completed is this now?
It is.
we have i think 10 games left yes 10 games i'm at 40 games
completed i'm trying to get to 50 games completed by the end
of the year so just 10 games left yuppie as she played
killer frequency i have i have played killer frequency
before yes yes thank you everybody this is fine this is fine
i'm sorry i couldn't show you the clock ending at least
sorry that i did not have a checkpoint so um but it was a
good time it was a good time so oh see you guys later thank
you so much everybody bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye bye-bye